[Música]
como una tradición a méxico así ha
calificado el presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador al no lograr la
aprobación de la reforma energética
el mandatario venía con un buen impulso
digámoslo así empoderado después de que
el 10 de abril los mexicanos
participaron en una consulta inédita en
ese país para elegir si removían o no
del cargo al mandatario si lo removían
de sus funciones según el instituto
nacional electoral cne entre el 93% y el
91,9 por ciento de los que participaron
apoyaron a lópez obrador en el ine
también indicaron que la participación
no pasó más allá del 18 2% muy por
debajo de ese 40 por ciento necesario
para que fuera un resultado vinculante
esta especie de triunfo o digamos tal
vez como una especie de victoria fue muy
cuestionada por muchos llevó a pensar
que el presidente se sentiría con poder
para llevar a cabo múltiples decisiones
sin dificultades incluso hay quienes
pensaron o piensan todavía que podría
contemplar el mandatario entonces la
posibilidad de querer quedarse en el
poder un poco más de tiempo dado este
apoyo de los mexicanos pero lópez
obrador ya dijo que no por eso voy a
seguir sirviendo hasta
el último día de mi mandato no me voy a
pasar
porque soy demócrata y no estoy a favor
de la
reelección quiero agradecerles porque
más del 90 por ciento
votó
para que yo termine mi mandato
+ d
15 millones de mexicanos
están
contentos y quieren que yo continúe
hasta septiembre del
pero contrario a ese buen viento ya esas
olas a su favor para navegar con
tranquilidad por la política mexicana el
mandatario ya tuvo su primer revés al no
lograr los votos suficientes para la
aprobación de la reforma constitucional
que limita a las empresas privadas o
extranjeras para entrar en la industria
energética mexicana y le da
prácticamente la totalidad o le daba
prácticamente la totalidad del control
al estado mexicano así lo anunciaba a
sergio gutiérrez el presidente de la
cámara de los diputados así anunciaban
los resultados de esa votación
en virtud de no alcanzarse la mayoría
calificada
con fundamento en lo que dispone la
fracción g del artículo 72
constitucional y en términos del
artículo 232 numeral 1 del reglamento de
la cámara diputados se desecha el
proyecto de decreto
desechado la mayoría votó a favor de la
reforma pero no alcanzó los votos para
que fuera un cambio constitucional así
las cosas el mandatario cargó contra la
oposición a quienes calificó de
traidores y también alegó que firmas
extranjeras compraron a los legisladores
para que no votaran por esta reforma eso
sí no presentó ningún tipo de evidencia
sobre esas denuncias fue la revocatoria
entonces un éxito o un revés para anv lo
que significa políticamente para el
mandatario no haber podido conseguir la
aprobación de la reforma energética que
tan allanado está entonces el terreno
para esas elecciones del 2024 para que
el partido morena se mantenga en el
poder todo esto mientras méxico sigue
registrando altas tasas de violencia
sobre todo asesinatos de periodistas y
de mujeres el panorama actual en mexico
lo analizamos aquí en el debate de
france 24 soy santiago lópez gonzález
para analizar entonces este tema hemos
invitado a alejandra toxtli ella es
analista política y magister en opinión
pública en marketing político también es
candidata a doctora en ciencias
políticas y sociales de la unam también
está con nosotros se origina de la
fuente de ellas magister en análisis
político de la escuela de gobierno y
transformación la pública del
tecnológico de monterrey en el norte del
país en el norte de méxico ustedes
también nuestros televidentes pueden
participar en este debate con los
comentarios y preguntas que deseen hacer
a través de las redes sociales estamos
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24
bajo ese santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal y nuestra etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas para
analizar este tema comienzo entonces con
alejandra preguntándole bueno primero
dándole la bienvenida del programa
alejandra gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en el debate de france 24 desde la
ciudad de mexico y quiero conocer como
punto de partida sus reflexiones lo que
significó para mexico esta consulta
revocatoria
significa también para el país no haber
sido aprobada esa reforma para la
industria energética mexicana
muchas gracias por la invitación bueno
de entrada respecto a la consulta de
revocación de mandato pareciera que ha
sido una consulta de estado ya muchos
habían comentado analistas que no parece
hacer una consulta ciudadana porque no
fue activada por los ciudadanos y porque
la pregunta era un poco ambigua en el
sentido de que si fuera aprobada o no
fuera aprobada esta consulta ciudadano
social si pasara y nos íbamos a mantener
como en un estatus donde ni hay avance
ni hay retroceso no estaríamos con
morena al final
siento y tengo la impresión que ha sido
como un tema que se vivió en su momento
que la opinión pública estuvo con el
tema durante quizás días antes de la
consulta y quizás son los 34 días y
parece ser que esta consulta ha salido
como perdiendo en la opinión pública por
el tema precisamente a la reforma
energética que fue desaprobada
si bien no no no creo que esta
consulta haya tenido un impacto directo
con el tema de la reforma es un tema muy
aparte hay que tener en consideración
que la consulta de revocación de mandato
fue una de las propuestas del candidato
al inicio
en ese entonces era candidato político
durante su campaña electoral mencionó
que ya sea precisamente esta consulta
entonces hay que tener en
conciencia que este tema y el otro son
totalmente distintos igual se mantuvo el
tema de la de las energías donde él
apostaba por mantener el tema de las
refinerías no entonces son temas
distintos y creo que no hay punto de
comparación entre uno el tema de la
consulta de revocación de mandato porque
es un ejercicio que por primera vez en
la alejandra pero que si lo que sí vemos
es que el partido está perdiendo un poco
de este voto duro porque en la primera
consulta vimos un apoyo de 16 millones y
ahora vemos de 15 quizás el techo se
mantiene en el sentido de que morena se
mantiene y quizás para la proyección del
próximo ejercicio para las elecciones
del 24 si alejandra podría ser pero si
alejandra tengo que darle paso a la otra
invitada para que también nos dé a
conocer su opinión sobre esta pregunta
de punto de inicio del debate solamente
tenemos 30 minutos para abarcar el tema
georgina bienvenida también al programa
le pregunto entonces por sus reflexiones
sus impresiones sobre lo que significa
para el presidente de lópez obrador y
para la política mexicana sobre esta
consulta revocatoria y sobre lo que
vimos en el congreso mexicano sobre esta
elección de esta reforma energética que
no jugó a su favor tampoco
buenas tardes de santiago alejandra
efectivamente viendo decías en un inicio
santiago este ejercicio fue histórico en
mexico no solamente porque es la primera
vez que la ciudadanía mexicana participa
en un en una consulta de esta índole
sino porque además no se jugaba
absolutamente nada y sabemos que el
presidente lópez obrador goza de una
popularidad muy alta y desgraciadamente
este ejercicio fue utilizado
no como un derecho de la ciudadanía sino
como una prerrogativa del poder como una
suerte de medición de músculo no previo
a las elecciones locales que tendremos
este año el año siguiente que está en
juego la gubernatura del estado más
poblado de méxico es el estado de mexico
y desde luego hacia 2024 me parece que
el este revocatorio sienta un muy mal
precedente
por tres motivos principales
santiago en primer lugar hubo una
promoción de la cultura del desacato y
de la ilegalidad de manera abierta desde
los niveles más altos del poder la
propia autoridad electoral tiene
registros altísimos
de quejas y denuncias que fueron
tramitadas ante sus instancias
competentes o por el uso ilícito de
recursos públicos para la promoción
de la asistencia de la ciudadanía a las
urnas
y también desde luego respecto a la
propaganda gubernamental las leyes de
propaganda gubernamental en los procesos
electorales y por otro lado algo muy
peligroso hacia nuestra elección de 2024
pero también las que siguen en las
locales este año y el año que entra
respecto al financiamiento para
el ejercicio de las funciones
constitucionales de la austeridad
electoral aquí en méxico bien sabes el
autoridad electoral es autónoma sin
embargo no hay una disposición en la ley
que permita blindar sus presupuestos y
una serie de altercados previos a este
ejercicio en la cámara diputados que
tanto el legislativo como la secretaría
de hacienda- negaron a la autoridad
electoral los recursos necesarios para
la organización de este ejercicio no
entonces la autoridad electoral se vio
limitada de recursos
avalado por la suprema corte de justicia
para la organización de este ejercicio
se sienta un muy mal precedente hacia
2024 o no y eso es precisamente una una
de las intenciones en manos a su
perversas por parte del orden para
seguir desprestigiando y atacando a la
autoridad electoral autónoma y es algo
que sin duda vamos a seguir viendo de
aquí a 2024 georgina continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda a la inversa
precisamente algunas de las impresiones
que uno puede recoger analístas allí en
mexico es que hay temor que este
referendo que no tenía un sentido lógico
desde el punto de vista político para
ser realizado se utilizó como una
herramienta tal vez para legitimar aún
más al gobierno de turno pero entonces
se desvirtúa ese instrumento democrático
que es un poco lo que usted estaba
explicando cuál es el futuro entonces el
precedente que sienta esto de cara a los
comicios que viene usted había
mencionado pero quiero profundizar allí
por supuesto
a mí me parece
peligroso en el sentido de que este
ejercicio en 2022 me parece que cambia
la dinámica del ejercicio presidencial
hacia el futuro para siempre porque
porque vemos a un presidente
con la intención de medir su popularidad
de utilizar este ejercicio para medir su
popularidad y permanecer en campaña a lo
largo de su mandato
cosa que desde luego pues no no no ayuda
a nada no no no no beneficia a nadie no
beneficia a la ciudad de mexicana a
nuestra democracia y desde luego tampoco
al ejercicio de la de las funciones
presidenciales que deben atender
ciertamente los temas más urgentes que
tenemos en la agenda nacional si
entonces esto abre la puerta para que en
el futuro futuros presidentes o
presidentas utilicen esta herramienta
disfrazada
de
peticiones en la ciudadanía para cambiar
la dinámica presidencial y que les
permita mantenerse en campaña hoy porque
como tú bien sabes aquí en méxico no
tenemos reelección para para presidente
sobre el señor heridas y entonces eso es
es muy grave que la dinámica
presidencial del ejercicio de las
funciones presidenciales haya cambiado
hacia el futuro alejandra está usted de
acuerdo con este punto que esto haya
cambiado la dinámica de la figura
presidencial en méxico y que pueda
sentar un precedente para que el
presidente de lópez obrador pueda
contemplar la posibilidad tal vez de
modificar la constitución para quedarse
en el poder que análisis puede hacer
usted
gracia santiago bueno como dice georgina
estoy de acuerdo en que las bases para
iniciar el próximo proceso electoral no
va a ser el mismo porque ya tienen de
entrada ventaja en el sentido de
identificar dónde tienen fuerza política
donde no tienen para mover sus bases y
obviamente tener pues este ventaja en en
el momento de obtener votos no entonces
eso de la disparidad a las elecciones y
sobre todo a los partidos que vienen en
contrapeso de morena entonces de entrada
pues eso dificulta una
un ejercicio como tal transparente en el
sentido porque en realidad ya tiene
ventaja no entonces no no no podría
decir que vaya directamente un cambio
constitucional pero lo cierto es que ya
ya podrían utilizar este ejercicio esta
consulta en próximos
comicios para indagar cómo está en
cuanto a su a su preferencia de no hay
sobre ella tomar ventaja en ese en ese
escenario alejandra supongamos que el
presidente actual andrés manuel lópez
obrador no puede aspirar a mantenerse en
el cargo porque la constitución así lo
indica que no puede superar el período
presidencial que tienen vigente pero
entonces cómo está el partido morena de
cara a ese escenario del 2024 después de
estos hechos que hemos visto en los
últimos días porque méxico políticamente
estaba muy movido en las últimas semanas
está preparándose y está muy afianzado
para el 2024 lo ve usted como una fuerza
bien parada para esos comicios y también
para esos comicios regionales que tienen
ustedes a la vuelta de la esquina que
análisis puede hacer
bueno de entrada igual este esta
consulta no se le puede atribuir un gran
logro en el sentido de concentrar
participación pero que como ya les había
comentado
esta fue una propuesta al inicio de la
campaña entonces ya se venía hoy a sedes
ya se tenía contemplado ya no hubo
tanto quizá estrategias para movilizar
sino que ya ya se venía trabajando
entonces
pareciera que el sentido o el rumbo de
las elecciones del 2024
tiene ventaja en morena en el sentido de
que ahora identifican donde tienen más
base donde tienen más votos pero creo
que igual esto le genera como un paso a
los partidos que van a hacerle
contrapeso en el sentido de que ahora ya
identificaron por dónde van por donde
podrían
y contrapeso no se logre poner de
acuerdo no logren como solidificar sus
bases porque incluso veremos que hay una
crisis en y tiene algunos partidos
entonces si podría tomar ventaja esté
morena y sobre todo porque pues ya se
está anticipando desde ahora o ingresá
mover gente y
pues incluso los programas de desarrollo
social se están utilizando como en ese
sentido para movilizarlo aunque
pareciera que en este momento en la
consulta vimos una disminución a un
millón que la primera consulta fue de 16
millones y ahora fue 15 millones no
entonces un poco que si resulta
cuestionable donde se ven semillas y
personas entonces están recibiendo su
apoyo están recibiendo su
el beneficio que ha puesto ambos desde
el inicio de la campaña hacia grupos
vulnerables
pero ahora ya no están yendo a votar o
qué sucedió en este sentido entonces el
rumbo de las
elecciones para el 2024 claro que les da
ventaja yo creo que ambas partes de esta
consulta ciudadana pero sin duda morena
no
georgina después de lo que vimos en el
allí en el congreso mexicano con esta
votación de la reforma energética
lo que se podría analizar es que el
presidente había salido con un poco de
impulso después de esa consulta
ciudadana porque los números así lo
indican fueron a su favor aunque muchos
dicen que no fue un triunfo no fue una
victoria simplemente pues fueron fueron
un indicador
de algunos de sus seguidores
prácticamente que fueron sus bases los
que más votaron allí pero el presidente
se mostraba muy seguro de aquí en lo que
le resta de mandato para hacer y tomar
decisiones un poco más fácilmente qué
fue lo que pasó ayer entonces porque
tuvo el presidente este revés con esta
reforma que él mismo estaba impulsando y
qué
le saca un poco la rabia al presidente
porque los acusó de traidores a los
opositores
y efectivamente lo que lo que lo que ha
pasado a lo largo de este proceso
legislativo en torno a la ley a la
reforma a la ley de la industria
eléctrica
tiene que ver
precisamente con estas características
que hemos visto en el ejercicio del
poder del presidente de la república y
en general de morena se han
caracterizado por
digamos ejercer
digamos sus funciones de manera
polarizante estás conmigo o estás en mi
contra cerrados al diálogo y me parece
que todavía hay una operación política
en el congreso como si estuviéramos en
2018 que efectivamente morena y sus
aliados contaban con una mayoría
calificada en el congreso me parece que
no ha cambiado esa esa visión en la
operación política de morena y de sus
aliados en el congreso porque a partir
de las elecciones intermedias de 2021 se
perdió esa mayoría
de tres cuartos que se requiere para la
aprobación de reformas constitucionales
aqui en mexico no y entonces toda esta
lógica se realizó un ejercicio
parlamento abierto para la discusión de
esta reforma en materia la industria
eléctrica
que fue cerrada para ciertos opinadores
especialistas propuestos por la propia
oposición este ejercicio se realizó a
modo de la mayoría legislativa que tiene
morena y precisamente se vieron cerrados
a mover una sola coma de la iniciativa
presidencial que había llegado al
congreso es decir tuvo apertura a la
oposición para dialogar para negociar
para mover absolutamente nada entonces
me parece que esto es reflejo de cómo ha
gobernado el presidente lópez obrador y
en general cómo ha ejercido la oposición
morena en realidad que no se sostiene
después de la elección de 2021 y
ciertamente si no hay un reconocimiento
de ésta no hay una apertura al diálogo o
una mayor disposición a la negociación y
en general al balance de fuerzas pues
inventarse que vamos a ver a un
presidente y a un morena en problema do
hacia 2024 yo bien entonces qué chances
pueda tener la oposición mexicana pueden
alinear fuerzas a partir de lo que
estamos viendo en estos recientes días
con estas votaciones es que es muy
diciente lo que ha dicho esta votación
de la reforma energética que
oportunidades entonces tiene la
oposición para estos dos años que restan
de mandato
mira algo que resulta gravísimo es que a
estos momentos la oposición sigue
fragmentada
tenemos una suerte de coalición
legislativa que nació en dos en
las elecciones anteriores
en torno a tres partidos al pri al pan y
al verde que se denominaba por méxico
pero tenemos otro partido más pequeño
movimiento ciudadano que ha ganado un
poco de terreno a nivel local con
ciertas gubernaturas clave por ejemplo
como como en jalis hoy el nuevo león que
son dos estados clave entonces la propia
oposición está fragmentada ahora también
hemos visto esta oposición fragmentada
en otras votaciones clave es decir
operaron en conjunto para esta votación
en particular pero en otras votaciones
en el pasado han operado de manera
fragmentada entonces aquí lo que tenemos
es que no hay una es la primera vez que
vemos a la oposición votar en bloque
y actuar o manejar un discurso
pues parejo no en el ámbito legislativo
sin embargo lo que destaca aquí santiago
es que hay una carencia de liderazgos
competitivos hacia 2024 suenan algunos
nombres ha habido por acá de ellos de de
algunas personas que se estarían
anotando pero nadie se ve que con la
fuerza o con la popularidad o con el
reconocimiento siquiera de parte de
chile el electorado entonces ahí hay un
reto importante para la oposición no hay
cuadros no hay liderazgos notables y eso
desde luego que va a generar una un
beneficio para morena claro que sí pero
del otro lado de la moneda alejandra
vemos un liderazgo sumamente marcado lo
decía el senador ricardo monreal quien
aseguró después de estas consultas y
estas votaciones que el principal activo
del partido morena era precisamente
andrés manuel lópez obrador pero
entonces quien puede llegar a suceder al
presidente
en el 2024 si no hay una y nos salimos
de ese terreno de la especulación que de
una reforma en mexico que le permita
quedarse a él en el poder quien puede
tomar las riendas de ese partido y de
méjico
abanderado con morena
bastante tenemos ahí un problemilla
porque precisamente lo que estamos
viendo ahora con el presidente es una
una polarización marcada no tenemos a
los que van en contra de su gobierno y
los mantiene con esa idea
para poder abanderar de forma legítima a
sus a sus futuros
vencedores en este proceso no tenemos
ahí en la mira buenos s se espera que
pueda ser en bound o brad en ese sentido
está en como que un poco alejados y ya
han sucedido bastantes situaciones que
los ponen en aprietos y que posiblemente
no tengan como una respuesta favorable
pero entonces lo que está haciendo
andrés manuel es cómo seguir esta
polarización marcada en cada una de sus
intervenciones en
las conferencias que ofrecen la mañana
no solamente para mantener está esta
polarización y está como
en
mantener su
voto duro y si bien como pensión
santiago precisamente en esta consulta
ahora que les mencionaba el número de
deportación que hubo
si comparamos
que en el proceso electoral de 2018
amplio recibió cerca de 30 millones de
votos y ahora en las consultas fue de 16
millones 15 millones tenemos la idea de
que en esa elección se salió a votar con
una esperanza una esperanza de cambio y
que ahora con el proceso de gobierno y
de esta administración como que
identificamos que se está perdiendo no
hay una buena decisión de toma de
decisión política de repente observamos
un presidente como muy
muy han tenido a esos temas
personales y que ya traía de antes que
viene arrastrando el tema de
que yo tengo que hacer está está esta
iniciativa esta política porque mis
contrincantes o las personas que estaban
antes no me lo permitieron entonces como
de repente se pierde esta idea de que
iba a tratar de resolver los problemas a
grupos sociales vulnerables no y
entonces ahora es un poco difícil
contemplar qué morena llegué como con
esa este fortalezas siles y comprendo
que va a llegar con una fortaleza y que
quizá es es posible que tengas morena
por otro sexenio porque bueno la
alternancia política dura por lo menos
23 gobiernos este
quieren que siga para que salga
precisamente la alternancia pero si
parece difícil y dar
este cargo que tiene en blog a alguien
más
por lo menos para que sea una oración
entonces ahí el análisis sería que desde
ahora está haciendo
marcando
quiénes son los buenos quiénes son los
malos y tratando de que el próximo
abanderado sea aceptado claro
georgina vemos que el presidente ya
lanzó otro as que tenía bajo la manga y
es busca nacionalizar la minería de
litio a futuro eso también va a generar
un completo debate y divisiones en la
sociedad mexicana ya vemos allí a las
fuerzas políticas también con
discrepancias en torno a este tema que
tanto se está jugando el presidente con
estas decisiones y que tanto le está
afectando esto o le puede llegar a
afectar o a beneficiar
políticamente este tipo de
decisiones de llevar al congreso estas
votaciones porque esto es como tal
parece que da la sensación que quiere ir
en contra de lo que acaba de pasar este
fin de semana con la reforma energética
si precisamente se discute hoy mismo en
el congreso en falta al proceso
legislativo porque no fue introducido a
las comisiones como debe de ser
cualquier iniciativa del presidente sino
que se se lanzó directamente al pleno y
en ese sentido a ello yo veo que el
presidente tiene más margen de maniobra
y la oposición
particularmente lo que tiene que ver con
los 3 partidos
coaligados
en el sentido legislativo pri-pan pero
ya anunciaron abstención a esta a esta
iniciativa es decir
no no genera el mismo impacto que tiene
que tuvo su iniciativa para relativa a
la industria eléctrica y aquí ya tenemos
por otro lado a movimiento ciudadano a
este partido más pequeño ella anunció
disposición para así participar en las
discusiones legislativas en donde
digamos que no encuentra mucha
diferencia y aquí el tema es que estas
reformas a este tipo de reformas legales
herencia de la de la industria eléctrica
no requiere tres cuartos de la
aprobación del congreso sino requiere
solamente mayoría simple y aquí sí lo
puede lograr con el apoyo de movimiento
ciudadano es decir son estas maneras de
encontrar salidas para el presidente
poder
adjudicarse digamos derrotas menores o
para generar un poco como decimos acá en
méxico colchón para que el golpe no no
sea tan un ser tan fuerte y eso es lo
que desde luego va a tratar de
promocionar para evitar
encuadrar o enmarcar esto como una
derrota en el en el legislativo bien lo
mencionabas hace un momento ella está
tildando a hacer a diputados y diputadas
de oposición como traidores a la patria
y eso desde luego es que digamos
seguimos en esta dinámica de
polarización es directamente no no ayuda
en méxico no ayuda nada a nuestro
ambiente democrático y que va a seguir
enrareciendo el ambiente y va a seguir
un poco radio radicalización de las
posturas hacia 2024 alejandra vamos
llegando a la parte final programa
quiero preguntarle muy puntual esta
subida de tono que utiliza el presidente
llamar a los opositores traidores de la
patria esto para la política para la
salud para esta polarización que ustedes
están viviendo que el presidente lo diga
abiertamente ante los medios de
comunicación
genera impacto entre la sociedad que
análisis puede hacer
de entrada estamos viendo un camino que
amenaza la democracia
analistas teóricos ya hablan de la
autocracia de una erosión democrática en
donde por ciertas razones la narrativa
del populismo aunque no se quiere
declarar futbolista block es
precisamente marcar esto de forma
directa no quiénes son los opositores
quienes son los traidores no entonces
esta situación
amenaza bastante el tema de la
democracia y sobre todo porque pues él
está ahora en el cargo y toma sobre eso
ventaja tiene medios de comunicación que
las 24 horas no están allí
y poniendo a la luz y que sin duda tiene
un efecto sobre la opinión pública
precisamente esta situación pues le da
ventaja
y en el tema democrático a ver todavía
no no hablamos de una erosión
democrática en él una autocrítica ción
pero pareciera que vamos en camino son
las situaciones que estamos viviendo por
un presidente omnipresente que está
tomando poder y una especie de
autocontrol de entrada de todas las
instituciones es sobre el estado de
alejandra
georgina mencionamos y analizamos este
tema de cómo el presidente sube de tono
que lo apoyan los ciudadanos así lo ha
evidenciado esa consulta ciudadana con
baja participación quienes siguen
apoyando al presidente y aquí uno otra
pregunta que necesito que las dos me
ayudan a responder y es quien está
apoyando al presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador cuando el país
económicamente no está en sus mejores
momentos la pandemia le costó un poco
despegar y ponerse a la par de los
países de la región en cuanto a los
planes para enfrentar la crisis
sanitaria los índices de inseguridad son
altísimos y los asesinatos de
periodistas y de mujeres en el país
siguen siendo un punto crítico que tal
parece que el presidente irá un poco por
encima del hombro porque es poco lo que
se ve que hacen las autoridades y lo
decimos desde la crítica
que uno puede ver de diferentes
analistas mexicanos que ven el tema con
preocupación cuál es su análisis
georgina
o aquí lo que tenemos en méxico es un
dominio total de la narrativa
comunicativa de desde el desde el
gobierno federal el presidente
sostiene conferencias de prensa todos
los días desde el palacio nacional en
donde coloca los temas prioritarios para
él y para su agenda y ese es el tema del
que se habla todo el día hasta el día
siguiente que vuelve a colocar los temas
que a él le interesan y en ese sentido
él ha sido muy efectivo en su estrategia
de comunicación para seguir controlando
digamos sus bases no es sin embargo aquí
yo tengo una una diferencia de opinión
con mi colega con alejandra en el
sentido de que yo yo no creo que se
puedan comparar sus 30 millones de votos
que obtuvo en el 2018 con la consulta
popular del año pasado o con la
revocatoria de este año me parece que
son ejercicios fundamentalmente
distintos
que fueron así que fueron difundidos de
manera distinta y que desde luego en
buena parte de la población mexicana no
hay un conocimiento
respecto
de qué se trata vengo de que se trató
este revocatorio de mandato suya y me
parece bastante grave que desde el poder
se
orquestó una campaña de desinformación
importante sigue teniendo apoyo de sus
bases como mencionabas desde luego la
mayoría de la gente que puede votar
pertenecen a sus bases en trato de la
movilización de
voto de las bases de morena y en ese
sentido ahí se midió el músculo que
tienen las entidades como bien
mencionaba alejandra si mantiene un
poder importante pero desde luego ya
erosionado y desgastado como es natural
en cualquier en cualquier periodo
presidencial pero es importante destacar
que el presidente sigue controlando la
narrativa pública todos los días
con mentiras abiertas
no nada más promoviendo los temas que
interesan sino mintiendo de manera
particular sobre los tecno lentes además
que si algo ha generado desgaste en los
gobiernos no solamente en el mexicano
sino a nivel mundial es el tema de la
pandemia de kobe 19 desgastó todas las
formas de gobierno posibles por esta
crisis sanitaria llegó ya la recta final
del programa me quedan pocos minutos
para hacer la conclusión alejandra
comienzo con usted que viene entonces
para méxico a nivel político y que va a
suceder entonces con el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador en estos
poco más de dos años que le quedan al
mando de la república mexicana
santiago bueno para cerrarse
en un escenario bastante complicado una
polarización
y sin duda es una gran ventaja para
morena porque ahora está en el poder
tiene tiene tanto poder político como
como poder económico para movilizar y
tomar ventaja en próximos comicios y
pareciera ser que en ese sentido pues
tenemos un morena para un un sexenio más
y que quiera su conclusión
si santiago muchas gracias como como
bien menciona mi colega y se vienen
tiempos complicados para la democracia
mexicana tenemos seis elecciones locales
este año en donde es si bien en morena
tenía casi asegurado el triunfo en cinco
de ellas ahora está más difícil y se ve
más bien que tiene el lugar de una
tambaleándose dos tambaleándose de esas
hacia el año que entra la elección en el
estado de méxico es el fundamental va a
ser volante sala de la elección de 2024
me parece que va a ser interesante ver
el en adelante como maneja en
presidencia lópez obrador estas
dificultades en el congreso de la unión
llegará a los comicios si no empieza a
cambiar
la fuente debo cortarla porque ya se me
acaba el tiempo de dar paso al
informativo álex alejandra también les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
y haber hecho este análisis de la del
panorama político el médico ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía sigan con
nosotros
[Música]